[Música]
les doy la bienvenida a un nuevo
episodio de boleto de vuelta que hoy nos
lleva a un rubin es una ciudad india
considerada como una utopía espiritual y
ecológica una ciudad sin dinero sin
gobierno sin religión que recibe a
personas de todo el mundo esa es occovi
una ciudad utópica fundada en febrero de
1968 en el sur de india por miga alfaz a
una francesa de pondicherry los
seguidores la conocen como la madre
dobló la ciudad en honor a su compañero
el filósofo indio río euro bindo
fundador de un movimiento espiritual que
busca la armonía en todos los aspectos
de la vida a la muerte de al fatá en
1973 la ciudad se desarrolló en medio
del desierto gracias a los trabajos de
sus habitantes actualmente 3 mil 300
personas de 52 países diferentes viven
allí la mitad de la población es india y
el 20% es francesa esta comunidad
experimental ha crecido con el apoyo de
la unesco y es reconocida por el
gobierno de india como una ciudad
cultural internacional con los años los
habitantes han transformado este
desierto en un bosque pues se han
plantado más de 3 millones de árboles la
ciudad se ha convertido en un auténtico
laboratorio viviente pionero de la
planificación urbana ecológica
[Música]
al amanecer la ciudad del alba se
despierta
rodeada de naturaleza angélica empieza
su día en bicicleta
[Música]
silence
este silencio es un momento del día en
que no hay gente es algo que libera mi
mente
hace 3 años angélica dejó su colombia
natal para instalarse en el sur de la
india
este oasis de 20 kilómetros cuadrados
tiene el tamaño de la ciudad de khan
angélica vino a probar una nueva forma
de vida
bien esta cocina comunitaria seis veces
por semana y cocina un promedio de 50
comidas al día con su equipo son comidas
para llevar
para los residentes de oroville que las
quieran
tenemos esta hoja donde la gente viene y
escribe su nombre su número de cuenta y
las porciones de comida que quiere
buenos días esta colombiana de 33 años
empezó a trabajar en esta cocina cinco
días después de haber llegado 20 24
porciones crees que necesitamos más hay
algunas en el cuarto frío
cada recién llegado debe involucrarse en
la comunidad uno puede elegir dónde
quiere trabajar nunca me imaginé
trabajar en la cocina no es una de mis
habilidades pero me encanta cuidar la
salud porque la comida de salud de la
comunidad
[Música]
an matilde valentín a una proteína una
ensalada un cereal
en oro vil independientemente de la
profesión todos reciben el mismo salario
225 dólares por mes las personas pueden
mantener sus trabajos normales siempre y
cuando donen parte de su salario a la
comunidad
si uno es un médico recibe lo mismo si
unos profesores recibe lo mismo todos
trabajamos por este sueño por la ciudad
y eso es hermoso
en otros lugares o no trabaja para
alimentarse y para alimentar a su
familia aquí aparentemente trabajamos
por lo mismo
darle su tiempo a la comunidad es uno de
los principios fundamentales aquí lo que
une a los 3.300 residentes de 60
nacionalidades
oroville fue un sueño el de mira al fas
a esta francesa que fundó esta ciudad
utópica era llamada la madre por sus
seguidores su retrato es un recordatorio
constante de que su sueño debe hacerse
realidad
imagino una sociedad sin dinero sin
nacionalidad sin política ni religión
esta esfera dorada es el símbolo de su
sueño
el matrimonio como se le conoce es el
corazón de la ciudad representa el sol
cayendo del cielo o saliendo de la
tierra
en su interior hay una sala de
meditación cerrada a las cámaras en ella
hay una bola de cristal aquí es donde
los habitantes de oroville vienen a
meditar en completo silencio
pierre legrand es uno de los primeros
residentes de la ciudad
cada vez es una alegría es como entrar
en otra dimensión es una atmósfera es un
lugar donde todos nos reunimos no al
mismo tiempo pero toda la gente cuando
tiene un problema crea una especie de
unidad nos ayuda a encontrar nuestra
unidad
le gran llegó en 1967 un año antes de
que se creara oficialmente la ciudad en
aquella época el lugar era un desierto
de tierra roja los primeros residentes
plantaron todos estos árboles ahora se
ha convertido en un bosque
antes era muy simple no había nada
unos años después cuando aparecieron los
primeros edificios que eran muy
futuristas era como ver una película de
ciencia ficción por lo que nos sentíamos
que estuviéramos en una realidad
ordinaria eso nos llevó porque estábamos
entrando en un sueño despierto era
realmente algo
ingeniero de formación dejo todo atrás
la vida cómoda en parís y su familia
para ser parte del sueño
tenía un amigo que era guardabosques y
me dijo en la india vi un montón de él
dijo chiflados vi un montón de chiflados
alrededor de una anciana que quería
cambiar el mundo y eso fue lo que me
llevó a por ese ring oroville todavía no
existía
del simulado con
este soy yo una choza con los
trabajadores tamiles
y esto es el interior de la choza
vivimos durante años en una casa de
palmas como esa
es gracioso ver a toda esta gente cuando
era más joven
le gran y los otros se inspiraron en los
acontecimientos de mayo del 68 al
principio eran unas pocas docenas de
personas y luego fueron un centenar
legrand estuvo presente el primer día de
la construcción del matrimonio
cuando digo que empezamos a acabar miren
había uno dos tres cuatro cinco personas
empezando a cavar un hueco era un hueco
muy pequeño y después cuando llamamos a
los habitantes del pueblo para que nos
ayudaran se convirtió en una obra era
como egipto es más que una utopía
realmente no es una utopía siempre queda
en el aire
cambiar el sistema
crear una nueva sociedad
con estos ideales llego krishna mckenzie
a oro vil
hace 26 años este escocés planto aquí la
primera semilla que se convertiría en
una granja forestal
su sueño era desarrollar un nuevo
sistema agrícola más sostenible
sólo podía hacerlo aquí en esta ciudad
experimental
me inspiró el sueño de la madre ella
decía oroville es un lugar de educación
y experimentación sin fin nadie me dijo
cuántas otras cultivar cuántas bananas
cultivar me dijeron este es tu camino
interior explora
esta granja realmente floreció con esa
libertad
mckenzie desarrolla técnicas de
permacultura
a diferencia del monocultivo que se
practica masivamente en todo el mundo el
principio es cultivar conjuntamente
diversas variedades de plantas se recrea
un ecosistema y las plantas se ayudan
mutuamente las más grandes dan sombra a
las más pequeñas las que pierden sus
hojas alimentan la tierra
sólo tienes que limpiar y devolverlo a
la tierra es así de sencillo
en estas dos hectáreas crecen casi 200
variedades de plantas
hay comida a cada paso hay plátanos que
hay berenjenas y marrones y hay guayabas
hay papaya y guanábana
hay tanta diversidad de alimentos en
esta granja
y todo ello equivale a una sociedad sana
y vibrante
para devolver a la comunidad krishna
mckenzie abrió este restaurante en el
corazón de su granja
a través de sus platos anima a sus
clientes de oroville a los de afuera a
ser más conscientes de su dieta les hace
descubrir ingredientes olvidados
esta es la ensalada de hierbas
silvestres pero también tiene papaya
rallada y mango rallado y flor azul esta
comida muchas veces no se puede vender
en una tienda normal porque la gente no
come tallo de banana la gente no come
estas hierbas comestibles estas papayas
verdes
todas estas espinacas silvestres la
gente prefiere comprar patatas
tiene que venir en un camión desde muy
lejos con un alto costo ecológico así
que esta comida representa un acto de
amor a la madre naturaleza
en oro vil hay una veintena de granjas
una parte de los productos llega a esta
cooperativa
allí encontramos a angélica
dice aquí está la sección de frutas y
verduras de oro vino el 45 por ciento de
los productos proviene de oro vino es un
supermercado que parece normal excepto
que aquí no hay precios a principios de
mes como cualquier otro residente
angélica hace una contribución de su
elección a la cooperativa y consume sólo
lo que necesita
es la lógica de que si estamos en una
comunidad compartimos y aquí no hay
golosinas no hay nada que no necesitemos
realmente los en sí es revolucionario
pero tiene que haber mucha confianza en
la comunidad
aquí están experimentando cómo crear una
sociedad que no dependa totalmente del
dinero en la caja no se necesita dinero
ni tarjetas de crédito
67 46 solo se registra el nombre del
cliente y los artículos comprados para
evitar excesos
adiós gracias
formar parte del experimento de oroville
requiere hacer algunos sacrificios
[Música]
hola
angélica vive aquí con su esposo azul
ven angélica ven no son propietarios de
su casa
esto ya
el principio de propiedad no existe en
oro vil
si algún día nos vamos dentro de uno dos
cinco diez veinte cincuenta años no
venderemos esta casa porque no nos
pertenece este jardín no nos pertenece
nada nos pertenece le pertenece a la
humanidad en la carta de oroville dice
que oro vil no le pertenece a nadie en
particular pertenece a toda la humanidad
todos somos humanos así que todos
tenemos las mismas tendencias de
sentirnos bien por poseer algo pero la
forma en que se sueña oroville o el
propósito vil no es tener propiedad
privada es tener propiedad colectiva
para angélica esta es una forma de vida
completamente diferente en bogotá era
arquitecta la esperaba otra vida
quieres probar
hay quien because
a mick sense que viene porque tiene
sentido todo aquí tiene sentido
trabajé como arquitecta durante ocho
meses y no pude una de las principales
razones fue para dejar de luchar contra
el sistema
medio siglo después la ciudad utópica no
ha prosperado tanto como se esperaba
orobitg es un proyecto ambicioso en
perpetua construcción
tobin human y sin duda llagares forman
parte del consejo de desarrollo de la
ciudad se han propuesto cumplir la
voluntad de la madre quieren seguir los
planos originales que se remontan a
finales de la década de 1960
todo se desarrolla gradualmente el matri
mandir los jardines se completaron
llegaron todo tipo de edificios los
sectores residenciales 1 y 2 empezaron a
tomar forma por primera vez cada vez que
uno viene año tras año se ve el cambio
mucho ha cambiado mucho ha cambiado pero
si se mira en general la madre quería
que en cinco años estuviera todo listo y
estamos muy lejos de completarlo
según los planos del arquitecto francés
roger anger aprobados por la madre
oroville debía tener la forma de una
galaxia una espiral formada por
edificios de varios pisos
vista desde el cielo la galaxia aún no
ha tomado forma
en su lugar se han creado un centenar de
comunidades dispersas en el bosque
dichas por modernas cabañas edificios
todos tienen su propio estilo
arquitectónico
la prioridad de este equipo dedicado al
desarrollo de la ciudad es construir
nuevas viviendas
ya que la ciudad se diseñó para acoger a
50.000 personas pero hoy sólo hay 3 mil
300 habitantes
el objetivo es que en los próximos 3 a 5
años vengan 10.000 personas el vigor
desgraciadamente hoy no podemos acoger
las porque no tenemos la infraestructura
necesaria en realidad las 3.000 personas
que están hoy aquí tienen el deber de
dedicar su vida a crear esta
infraestructura para las 47 mil personas
que vendrán acá jóvenes ancianos
para hacerlo realidad los residentes de
oroville le pidieron al gobierno indio
120 millones de euros
quieren rejuvenecer esta utopía
adormecida
los sueños de la fundadora aún no se han
hecho realidad pero hay un pequeño rayo
de esperanza la población de la
comunidad ha aumentado esta década
un centenar de personas se instalan en
oro vil cada año en busca de
espiritualidad y valores ecológicos
llegamos al final de este episodio de
boleto de vuelta a un hobby recuerde que
si quiere ver este y otros episodios en
español puede visitar nuestra página web
france24 puntocom hasta pronto